question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture de 20 à 30
euros le mégawattheure début 2020 à 800
euros le mégawatt-heure en septembre
dernier les prix de l'électricité flambe
cette réalité vécue par l'ensemble des
Français affectent aussi nos
agriculteurs ce qui doivent renégocier
leur contrat de fournitures
d'électricité avant la fin de l'année
sont accablés par les tarifs auxquels
ils se retrouvent soumis leur facture
est multipliée par 5 x 10 W + avec de
telles hausses l'amortisseur électricité
prévue par le gouvernement ne suffira
pas il ne permettra de prendre en charge
qu'un quart a un tiers du surcoût
énergétique pour les exploitations du
moins pour les agriculteurs qui sont
éligibles certaines entités agricoles
avec un statut hybride ne sont
effectivement pas assurés de pouvoir
bénéficier de cet amortisseur
énergétique par exemple le syndicat
d'irrigation de rommois syndica
intercommunal qui gère une régie
d'exploitation
mais malheureusement éligible à aucune
aide pourtant sa facture énergétique va
passer de 2 millions et demi d'euros en
2020 à 30 millions d'euros l'année
prochaine ils s'ensuit que le prix du
mètre cube d'eau qu'il facture aux
exploitations pas plus que quintuplé
remettant en cause la pérennité des
exploitations agricoles dromoise la
nouvelle donne énergétique va entraîner
la faillite de nombreux agriculteurs
dans toute la France la production de la
ferme France sera réduite d'autant au
détriment de notre souveraineté agricole
et alimentaire et j'exploitant devront
répercuter leur nouvelle charge
énergétique sur leur prix au détriment
de la compétitivité de notre agriculture
cela favorisera les importations au
détriment de nos productions locales
cela mettra en difficulté l'emploi
agricole et la logique des circuits
courts tant défendus monsieur le
ministre les agriculteurs ont besoin que
la hausse des prix de l'électricité soit
plafonnée à 120 mégawattheure que leurs
exploitations restent viables alors
allez-vous leur garantir à tous la
protection dont ils ont besoin